and I'm not even that like I'm not a
left-wing guy I'm not a right-wing guy
I'm just a guy that looks at things and
goes we're beyond Fox right and how look
I don't think it's helpful that now if
if if if a 17 year old comes up and goes
by the way uh I'm from another planet
and you go wait what dig oh you're a
Nazi right that's not helpful
yeah that's not helpful it became a
little dangerous when you were
considered like punk rock to think
there's like two genders right that day
came I was like wait what you're like a
bad guy yeah no there's like men and
there's women and they're like wow
there's no logical print there's no
rational logical person that when you
say to them there's actually an
innumerable amount of genders nobody
believes that no people are either
terrified into opening their mouths
there's not a human being on earth that
did that make sense to okay nobody even
the person saying that they're offended
that purse has been bitten here oh
there's a lot of people that have been
bit that's the problem
you look at them you go they do your
fear oh yeah and put your letters right
to the right you have people talking
about race and IQ and we're gonna there
needs to be an ethnos state and we're
gonna and you go oh your fear oh yeah
you got bit right and then the New York
Times writes this article where they're
like well people went down a youtube
rabbit hole and ended up radicalized
right into the right which is easy to do
according to the New York Times and
listen I get it it's eat you can get
records a lot of people are on YouTube
going why does my life suck or some of
them are just bored so they just go and
they start here and then they end up
somewhere in the nether regions of the
internet watching David Duke right or
whatever but then you also got to
realize that happens to the left yeah
the newer times acts like there's no
such thing as left-wing extremism and
then go on tumblr and there's somebody
that's identifying as a cat yeah
well that person was radicalized by
something right people that are calling
themselves other kin I'm a fairy I'm a
pixie I'm a pansexual queer identifying
demi bleep like this is both sides
completely yes salon.com to hear you
talking about Pharoah Benjamin
like a house cat like he's yeah in the
same way where he's like black people
like why do they have so much black
about crime is that you're from Sherman
Oaks you've never lived anywhere but
Sherman Oaks right met a black person
three times
Candace Hollins Candace oh yeah but
that's the thing and you have to now
deal with rabid zombies like their
people mmm-hmm and that's because
everybody has a place at the table so
somebody saddles up to the table and
start spouting craziness and you have to
sit there and go oh right really when
did you first realize that you were a
woman in the morning but then a man for
lunch and then uh or when did you
realize that gender fluidity was the
thing well what article did you read
were you self diagnosed yourself as
being gender fluid I'm not saying that
there aren't legitimate cases of people
that don't identify as either gender
okay that's fine
but you get one [ __ ] designation
right one thing yeah you don't get an
innumerable amount of [ __ ] things
that's it you you you you okay I'm
non-binary good then that's it you can't
be 5000 different make-believe genders
that you've come up with because you
read The Chronicles of Narnia and you
want to be a thorn these are all nerds I
mean me and Malin talk about it yeah
there's a lot of nerds in the trans
community yeah real big nerds yeah I
have a hell of respect for like trend
real transvestites and transsexuals
Brian so got the clubs and have fun and
do coke and fight each other on the
streets and Greenwich Village yeah beat
the [ __ ] out of each other on the C
train yeah I don't think these these
[ __ ] are nerds yeah hormonal Geek
Squad they're nerds yeah if [ __ ] Lord
of the Rings has become the new like
[ __ ] is weird like Game of Thrones
[ __ ] what is this what kind of
training are you well actually Westeros
I mean it's like wait a minute what
right we've made [ __ ] into